there were a lot of twists and spiderman
far from home some that we expected and
some that we didn't expect how's it
going everyone it's Warren and don't
worry I won't be talking about any
spoilers for spider-man far from home in
this video if you have not seen it yet
now before spider-man far from home came
out there were a lot of leaks about the
movie obviously a lot of them ended up
not being true like the one that stated
that we would be introduced to Oscorp
and the sinister six and one of the
post-credits scenes for the movie now
obviously and sadly if you have seen the
movie you know that this did not happen
in fact no mention of any future villain
for the next spider-man film was
mentioned at all in the post-credits
scenes however today thanks to the
director of spider-man far from home Jon
Watts we do have an idea of who the next
villain could be in the next spider-man
film thanks to what he said in an
interview so let's talk about this
villain that the director has named also
a quick reminder if you'd like a chance
to win a Captain America shield and Iron
Man helmet and Infinity Gauntlet or
another Marvel Legends item be sure to
subscribe to my channel to enter my
giveaway I'll be picking three winners
at four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers so of course after
spider-man far from home came out John
Watts has been asked many questions
about the movie including why he didn't
bring back some villains into the movie
like vulture or scorpion and also what
his plans are of course for the next
villain in the next spider-man film in a
recent interview he stated that he
really enjoys introducing characters
that the audience has never seen on the
big screen before and when he was asked
about which character he would introduce
as the villain in spider-man 3 he
replied I always just tried to start
with what we haven't seen before and
there's so many Spider Man villains I
mean the fact that I got to bring
hydro-man and molten man to a movie
really I get a kick out of that but no I
don't know who's next I always like to
think about it in terms of what's going
to be the most difficult thing for Peter
so that's going to be the next trick now
he says he doesn't know but when he is
asked again he actually mentions a
villain by name when he was asked again
he said oh I would love Kraven it's just
the trick of how do you do Kraven in a
movie now what's really really
interesting about his answer Kraven as
the next villain in spider-man 3 is that
we've known for some time now about two
years that Sony has been developing a
Kraven the hunter movie for their own
universe in fact in August they hired
Richard Wenk to write the script for the
Kraven the hunter movie everybody just
assumed that this is going to be a
Kraven the hunter movie but what if it's
actually a script for spider-man 3 and
Kraven the hunter is going to be the
villain this actually ties in pretty
perfectly with how spider-man far from
home left off and one very important
thing to note is that Kraven the hunter
is the half-brother of chameleon who we
saw in the movie and the comics
chameleon is the one who calls Kraven
the hunter to go and defeat spider-man
and considering the mid-credits scene
for spider-man 5 from home this makes
sense and wouldn't be that hard and
there will probably be a lot of people
hunting spider-man in the next
spider-man film so it's a perfect
opportunity and setup to introduce
Kraven the hunter in spider-man 3 now
john watt said that his concern was how
to do it how to introduce Kraven the
hunter but a lot of people were
wondering how he was going to introduce
Mysterio and all this illusions on the
big screen and he absolutely killed it
Mysterio was one of the coolest villains
to see on the big screen especially with
all of his illusions and Watts did a
great job of incorporating some aspects
from the comics into the movie as well
so I have no doubt that he would have no
problem introducing Kraven the hunter in
spider-man 3 what are your thoughts on
John watts the director of spider-man
far from home and the next spider-man
film teasing the introduction of Kraven
the hunter as the villain of the next
spider-man film be sure to let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
also be sure to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway and stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof